and here in new york opening statements
begin this morning in r kelly's federal
trial the r b singer is charged with
racketeering for the alleged sexual
exploitation of children and a series of
other counts related to illegal sexual
activity r kelly denies all those
charges attorney steve greenberg has
represented r kelly since 2018
he left the defense team here in new
york last month over disagreements with
two other lawyers on the team but he
still represents kelly in illinois and
minnesota and he joins us only on cbs
this morning mr greenberg good morning
i guess we should begin with your
expectations for the opening remarks at
trial today with the bigger
understanding that this is a legal team
you're no longer part of
right well i i think what they have to
do in opening statements today is
uh just convince the jurors that r kelly
is not the monster that the
public has come to think
that he is the government i expect is
going to have a very
detailed opening they're going to
present all sorts of uh stories that
these women they suppose are going to
tell they they allege are going to tell
but then what the defense has to do is
they have to humanize r kelly they have
to tell the jurors how this is someone
who started out singing in subways and
really as a celebrity
he just sort of lived his life and made
his music what people are going to find
out is that
the
sort of the moral view that we all have
and and kind of the me too movement has
changed the way we looked at things but
in the moment things were happening we
didn't look at them that way and they
weren't illegal so is the argument going
to be that these women are lying or that
what the women are alleging may be
disagreeable
and true but it's not a crime
well i think it's going to be a
combination of all of that
i think that some of the women are just
out and out lying i think that some of
the women are exaggerating i think that
some of the women are perhaps telling
the truth about what happened but it's
just not a crime what the government has
done here is they they've used the rico
statute which really is intended to
prosecute gangs and mobsters and they're
trying to prosecute an individual for a
bunch of acts where the statute of
limitations has expired or they were
minor acts and they've sort of blown
them out of proportion by using this
rico law in my opinion it's it's just a
complete uh perversion of the intent of
the rico law so when you talk about
sweeping up these minor acts into the
bigger crime under the rico law what
what are you considering to be a minor
act what would the defense be willing to
concede as true to try to get r kelly
off in this case
well i think the one that everyone's
heard about the most is an allegation
that he gave people herpes which
actually is not what the law says
uh the new york prosecutors are using a
new york state law and that's the only
reason the case is actually in new york
that's how they get what we call venue
and they're using that misdemeanor law
that no one's ever been prosecuted
against
to try and
get a foothold in new york on a felony
case
when a prosecutor has to get
truly creative as they have in this case
then that's probably not what the law
was intended to punish or prohibit
what do you say steve to people that say
listen there have been rumors for years
about r kelly abusing women and and
certainly young girls
what do you say when you say the defense
has to humanize him or even show that r
kelly is a victim how can they do that
when so many of these women and young
girls are telling the same stories who
have no ties to each other
they can't all be lying can they
well and everyone in a criminal case
people don't all have to be lying for a
defendant to prevail in a criminal case
um
what's abuse gail that's really what
this comes down to so you've got
different categories
of offenses here you've got
alleged minor victims
some of which i think you're going to
find out lied about their age their
families lied about their age and they
really tried to capitalize on r kelly
and extort him for money
and then you've got other things which
they've alleged like he wanted people to
call him daddy now how is that any
different from me saying i want to be
called honey or sweetheart
maybe it's a different word but it's
still the same concept so steve's
teaching
the difference between being called
daddy and being called sweetheart and
honey in the context that these girls
were saying but that they were kept
locked up these are these are grown gale
these are grown no no these are not
capital active rooms these are grown
women uh for the most part who who made
a choice to be with an individual who
was a celebrity when they talk about
being in a locked room
they would go to the studio they would
be told wait in this room someone will
come and get you there's no chains
there's no hooks in the floor like we
supposedly heard about in that so-called
documentary there's none of that if i go
to visit somebody at a police station i
get put in a room and told i can't leave
the room if you go to certain places you
get told wait in the room these women
waited sometimes three four five hours
while he was recording music but that's
not being locked in a room forever and
held days on end like you see in some of
these uh sex slave kind of cases
yeah and that's right and that's why we
have trials yeah that's why we have
trials that's why we have
cross-examination and that's why we
should all keep an open mind until the
end so you're and you're saying mental
abuse if that's what it is isn't a crime
well mental abuse isn't a crime that's
absolutely correct so what's happened
here is we've got the me too movement
and so we look at something and we say
well this was abuse but is it against
the law that's really what you have to
do and that's what they have to do an
opening statement today is get that
across to the jurors that there's a
difference between what's morally
incorrect or me too incorrect and what's
legally incorrect steve you were there
that day we did the interview with r
kelly and i'm curious about your um
characterization of that and the reason
why i'm asking you specifically is
because later r kelly was said to me or
sent word to me that he was thanking me
for giving him the platform to express
himself because we got to see he says
his passion and his pain do you think
that interview hurt or helped him
i think to some people it helped and to
some people it hurt i you know if our
kelly had sat there with you perfectly
stoic everyone would have said he
doesn't feel bad about anything he's got
no emotion he's got no feeling he got
very upset during that interview that
was very real that was how he felt that
is how i feel that he's being taken
advantage of here the problem is no
matter what the man does people are
going to criticize but all that matters
gail and you know this is what those 12
people in the courtroom think in some
three or four weeks from now all right
all right steve greenberg thank you very
much we appreciate you getting up with
us